Mass Effect Andromeda takes place in a
brand new galaxy which means all the
many characters and locations of the
previous games are left behind however
that doesn't stop a few Easter eggs and
references from slipping through here
are all the ones we found in our time
with Mass Effect Andromeda don't worry
there are no major spoilers but if you
want to find these for yourself
subscribe so you don't forget about this
video and then come back and let us know
what we missed the only familiar face
fans will encounter an Andromeda isn't
any living creature but the VI Avena
approachable intelligence designed to
assist you with immigration vena acted
as the informational terminal and guide
back on the Citadel and it seems her
program was copied for the Nexus you
will however hear a familiar character
voice in some audio messages from dr. Li
ara to Sony
I am dr. Li ara to Sony and I've spent
several decades researching ancient
Protheans she's giving writers dad
archaeological advice on how to handle
studying ancient ruins in Andromeda it's
not fully clear when these were recorded
but her more optimistic tone probably
places them before she meets Shepherd in
Mass Effect one tearing canned Rose is
the head of the militia on the Nexus if
asked about his reasoning for moving to
Andromeda he says how he was tired of
being the good one and mentions how he
had a cousin named Irene who went pirate
on Omega those who played Mass Effect 3
Omega DLC will recognize her as he
seemed Nerine canned Rose who led the
mercenary group the talons helping
Sheppard and Aria take back Omega from
Cerberus more family relations come from
a cat hunter you meet on EOS named Bane
Missoni he mentions that he never met
his dad but heard he was some big-time
mercenary all I know is he gave me his
name and nothing else his dad would be
none other than Mass Effect 2 squad
members ie Missoni
down in the sons of Coderre you'll run
into cassandra Verner who says she left
the Milky Way to get away from her
brother her brother being none other
than reoccurring joke character and
Shepard fanatic Conrad Verner like her
brother though she seems to be just as
crazy I want to work for her the ropes
then call it my brother Conrad and
beyond see idiot you're not the only one
in the family hanging out with famous
people right good luck with that another
character named Rob comes from a former
tureen Specter you meet on hvar oh he
mentions that the one who recommended
him to the council was none other than
Saren Arcturus mass effect ones main
antagonist Saren the rogue Spectre who
led the goth attack on the Citadel if
you believe the rumors the Sara I knew
was ruthless not crazy like Shepard
before them
Reiter can start their own model ship
collection many ships from the series
can be found including the Normandy sr2
you can find it in Alec riders room on
the Hyperion Andromeda comes with plenty
of new suits and armor but if you're
itching to wear something a little more
familiar you can research the n7 armor
that Shepard uses in Mass Effect 3 the
only thing missing is the iconic red
strip on the right arm but a quick trip
to the customization terminal can fix
that in non Mass Effect related
references you can find plants vs.
zombies plushies in someone's bed on the
tempest plants vs. zombies garden
warfare 2 had his own Mass Effect
reference with a special z7 skin for the
IMP and its Tzemach a model of this
exact skin can be found on Ryder's desk
finding memory triggers will unlock
special audio logs on Alec Ryder's
computer they are worth doing for the
extra story details and also contain
some familiar voices one of them being a
recording from the Shadow Broker
barliman says you're looking for me it's
not everyday and exams and ones for the
shadow broker the final memory unlock
contains what is perhaps the best Easter
egg in the whole game it's so cool in
fact that we won't spoil it here
Mass Effect Andromeda is a huge game
with plenty to miss so there are
probably even more Easter eggs and
references we didn't cover in this video
let us know if any you guys have found
in the comments and for even more Mass
Effect Andromeda coverage I made a video
about how to pull off sick power combos
in combat and of course make sure to
check out our full review everything's
under control just a simple weapon
malfunction how are you
[Music]